it's going to be 20 girls aha and one
guy what would you advise the girls
going into the house you know the
situation with all the cameras and you
know all the situations that yeah so
what would you tell the girls okay I
think that I would say try your best to
make him feel special I know that seems
weird because there's all these girls
going after him but for me the people
that stood out the most were the ones
who made me feel like we were in a
relationship like who really showed how
much they liked me and weren't afraid to
do that just because they were amongst
others and I think feeling like you're
in a relationship with someone is
important thing and that's actually what
Kevin did it for meeting you yeah
everything out weird I did it was
stressful and stuff so and having
someone who you feel has your back is
nice and what do you think these girls
could learn from our American partners
and Corrine and the gang I think
currently yeah I think focus on why
you're there and building a relationship
with with the bachelor and not so much
on you know your friendships or enemies
in the house I think it's good to have
friendships because you need it because
you need sanity but but I don't think
that focusing on the negative stuff will
get anywhere no which leads us into
correct okay you know it's kind of
amazing a little bit yeah in the
broadest sense of that word what is your
take on current okay I think that
Corinne is obnoxious and she's you know
annoying and all of those other things
but the one thing I will say about
Corinne is that she doesn't
intentionally go out to get the other
girls the only reason that she's been
mean is in retaliation to not draw else
being mean to her which was Taylor we
had her name Taylor and so that's I
don't think she's so bad yeah she's kind
of like annoying but that's only because
as women were like oh stop being so full
of I also think she's bringing it a
little she's jealous right she's putting
it on but I think she could have gone
one way Shadow would have cowered down
yeah and then would have been train
rolled yeah right or she does which
doing yes made an amazing television
yeah and she's only been mean back so I
think that the villains that I don't
like are the ones who are bullying and
right being mean to the other girls and
she's not really being mean she's being
herself
and the other girls just don't like it
they don't I think they're resentful of
her because Nick likes it
well then the other thing is she's
obviously a very sexual girl right I'm
not something that she's sort of brought
yeah the forefoot which then again what
kind of advice would you give the girls
in terms of because he's our intimate
relationship yeah and you'd have to be
considered yeah what would you advise
the girls there I would say definitely
don't hold back in and how you feel but
make sure that you're exploring all
elements of that relationship and you
know like I think that I don't know I
think she I know it's kind of like a
fine line because you don't want to come
on too strong
I want to Corinne it in about no you
don't want to Corinne it about your
castle at all but if you're attracted
physically and there's that chemistry
there then definitely let that be there
but just just don't go overboard because
I think that gives the wrong impression
too and you can and even if you want to
just be yourself you have to be a little
bit mindful of the fact that you you
have only so much time right do you ever
have time where you were with one of the
gentlemen and you actually forgot the
camera was there and you're at whole ole
ole-ole
bring it back I feel like what Kevin and
I we were making out all the time and
you're just on feed because therefore
they're like ah get rid of the photos
yet too much of it yeah but um yes sorry
I guess so I guess so do you think that
Jenny back to your Corinne again her
tactics will work or are working with
Nick I think that he's really attracted
to her and I think that he's attracted
to her confidence so in a way it's
working but I don't think it's going to
take her all the way